Since its founding, America has enjoyed
population growth famously fueled by
high immigration rates. But Americans
have historically had very large
families compared to other countries, as
well. But times are changing. Birth rates
today have fallen to their lowest point
in history, and while birth rates have
historically been connected to economic
cycles, the present decline is happening
during good economic times. The causes of
the decline will be familiar for many
viewers: high housing costs, less dating
and marriage, economic and social
uncertainties. And even though surveys
show Americans still want big families,
there are no cheap, easy solutions to fix
this problem. And unfortunately, the
problem is self-reinforcing. Fewer
children means that future generations
will have fewer workers serving more
people, who themselves will have less
time to bear and care for children — or
retirees for that matter. Even if
Americans reform housing policy, or offer
greater financial support for families,
our birth rates will continue to decline,
and the fast economic growth that made
America so strong in the 20th century
could vanish in the 21st. So what do you
So what do you
think about this? If you could go back in
time and have your life turn out any way
you wanted, how many children would you like to have? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.